i've talked to you any number of times
but i never actually asked you a
question that has
like been on my mind a little bit you've
been famous since
you were very young like you became a
child star
um and it feels like you are the sanest
former child star
that's a lot of therapy andrew a lot of
therapy
it's hard man i mean and it's hard in
the best of circumstances
i think i had one of the best
experiences
because i was you know on a show for
eight years so i had stability
um my parents had their own lives so it
was never
uh you know a question of them pushing
me into this
um and i recognized that it was
important to be self-reflective at a
really young age but i'll be honest i i
mean
i've struggled with anxiety and
depression and i think a lot of it has
to do with trying to
to figure out what that part of me and
where that part of me lives as an adult
you know and i think i have this this
conversation all the time with my
therapist
about like he'll say to me you know
people
you think people look at you as
a child star but they don't like you
almost have to remind them because
you're so far away from that now and
there's so many generations
that don't know you as that and so but i
do think that there is a lot of my
adulthood where i was
trying to prove that
not only was was it not going to happen
to me where i was going to end up a
statistic
about you know the young child actor who
who winds up being in rehab and and
you know like that i was sure that that
was not going to happen to me and i made
it so
but also that i was worth more than just
being a child
actor you know and i think any child
prodigy would relate to that
you know i think even if you played
chess and excelled at that at
at a young age as you grow up there's
this thing
that that you don't you got to figure
out what your worth
is as a grown-up and it took me a lot of
years to do that
and i've worked really hard at it so i'm
super proud of it and the interesting
thing
thing is once i got to this point where
i was like
yeah i'm a badass you are a badass
alyssa
as much and i'll tell you why because
i feel like i fought for so long to
figure out who i was and to be okay with
that person
that the idea of having to portray
someone else the idea of like
embodying someone who
was going through hardship was really a
very weird concept for me i just did a
movie in vancouver
um and it was the first thing i'd i had
done since i
you know since covid page 14
she finds out her sister is dead so
the entire shoot i am
digging so deep for emotion because
i mean that's what we do as actors we
gotta we gotta use what we have inside
of us to invoke
emotion and i i was a little resentful i
got to tell you because i was like
why am i doing this why am i making
myself cry every day i have a job
where it is my job to make people cry
every single day and i have to go to
some dark places sometimes to get
to that point and so the the
the more involved i got in
self-reflection and therapy and
exploration and all of that it became
harder and harder for me to to go to
work and
act it's an interesting it's an
interesting thing and and
you know i think i'm really proud of the
work that i just did
in this movie so yeah it sounds like you
did a great work if you it would be it
sounds like it was
like you know like you really had to dig
deep so it must have been good
so so i have to figure out like why i'm
still feeling a sense of pride
even though it was so hard for me to go
through it
i mean you know you know there's there's
certain things that we choose to do
that we're like in the middle of it
we're like why did i say yes to this
i've had that thought a couple of times
like running for president you know
there were moments on the presidential
campaign i was like well like what did i
get myself into again like you know in
like uh
um you know week two in the winter away
from the family or whatever it was
you were so brave to do what you did
oh thank you alyssa i mean again you
were there with us uh but
what i i thought to myself in the
beginning was like you know what i'm
going to just do
everything in my power to accelerate the
end of poverty i've got a two-year
window
and just whatever it takes we're going
to do it
and so when things got tough i would
remind myself of that i would just think
about like how many
lives can i change you know it's
potentially every once in awhile because
i like numbers and stuff i would even
think about i'd be like
i'm fighting for like a trillion dollars
in poverty relief because there's no way
to get there without the government
and you know that the
the biggest question i got on the trail
was like where are we gonna get the
money
and then here we are less than two years
later and everyone's like oh yeah we had
the money
it turns out of course they have the
money you know and when you think about
the the places that money goes
instead of other places it's it's
infuriating
you know i mean i do a lot of work for
the national endowment of the arts and
we do a lot of lobbying
and i mean the budget this year is
something
ridiculous like a hundred and six
million dollars that's so
low so allowed a four trillion dollar
budget
i was like you know what can we just
maybe what if we just ask for
one dollar per person for the national
endowment of the arts
what if we just tried you know i don't
know let's see what happens
with a budget of you know 380
million right so that we have
one just that's all i'm asking for one
dollar for people to express themselves
because i have this philosophy of like
the first thing
the first inclination that a child has
that we
as adults or parents are proud of them
is what it's a piece of art that we
usually play yeah that's when they draw
something
even my kids crummy drawings alyssa we
stick it up
i have so many crummy drawings of my
kids but you know that's what gives them
their
their self-pride and their you know so
it is really amazing the things we spend
money on and
the the fact that anyone lives below the
poverty line in this country is
infuriating and it should make every
single person mad
yeah i can go through some of the recent
relief bills so
the argument i made when someone asked
me it's like where you need the money i
was like do you remember anyone asking
where we're going to get the money when
we
uh gave wall street uh trillions of
dollars for the bailout and they were
like uh
no and i was like yeah there you go so
the the
uh cares act that came out the 2.2
trillion when everyone got 1200
checks i think that the 1200 checks and
all the money that came to families was
something like 17
of the headline cost like it turns out
we could have given everyone
a thousand bucks a month for six months
for the same amount of money
uh just like 83 this is what you've been
saying for years
yes so just an illustration that you
know we we actually
do have the money did have the money um
but i do feel like
things are coming uh this direction
because more and more people are like oh
yeah we could do this totally if we just
decided to do so
um but uh so it's funny because i do
think that there are some parallels
between
um like running for office which you
might do which we're going to ask you
about a minute
um but like running for office had some
elements
of um like the creative process
uh because when i was on the road um you
know i'd show up and there'd be a small
group of people and i'd be like hey i've
got this vision and like you know you're
trying to like engage them and excite
them
and and and you're and in my case like i
was genuinely like excited to
to talk to people um but even if you had
a cold or whatnot like you still had to
you know be the show must go on
yeah there's an element of it and uh you
know and then you hope that they tell
their friends and then like the next
time you come back it it's bigger and
better uh
uh and and so there there are some
parallels and
it you know some of the overlaps it's
not great because you can sense that our
politics are kind of degenerating at the
theater
or performative right
i feel the same way about activism
actually
oh my gosh that is probably a hundred
percent correct
i think that activism has become
very performative and i think this
cancel culture that's calling people out
culture is an act of uh
of performance and i think that you know
you're a science guy right like the
brain lights up there's certain cortexes
or
whatever they're called that lights up
when you call someone out
on social media and so the reward center
of someone saying uh you know what
that's not uh people are getting
rewarded for that
and therefore they continue to do it and
it is not in any way um
helpful at all so
so yeah so i believe that there's a lot
of activism that's performative
as well
[Music]
you